commuters in patient for change are used
to hearing excuses but for rail
travelers in the north it's not just
trains that have been cancelled but
whole lines there'll be no hs2 to leeds
or high speed line west to manchester
both victims of a cost-cutting plan that
breaks the prime minister's promise to
deliver both though that's not how he
put it what we're doing is not just the
big why
of hs2 but we're also doing northern
powerhouse rail that runs from uh from
liverpool uh warrington to manchester uh
to to leeds to york
in fact there'll be just 40 miles of new
track northeast of manchester with
upgrades to existing lines making up the
bulk of a 96 billion pound package of
improvements the labour leader quick to
point out the gap the north of england
have been betrayed because the prime
minister made two very important
promises hs2
all the way
to leeds a new line um that promise has
been ripped up he also promised the
northern powerhouse rail a new line from
manchester to leeds and that plan has
been ripped up
there was anger from the prime
minister's side too among the mps who
banked his promises so i have to say
madam deputy speaker that i am deeply
disappointed by today's announcement the
bradford district has been in my view
completely shortchanged this is the
danger in selling perpetual sunlight
and then leaving it for others to
explain the arrival of moonlight
the impact will be felt acutely here in
leeds where a promised new tram network
may not compensate for the loss of two
high-speed lines
the government insists its cheaper plan
will deliver similar journey times to
high-speed rail but northern powerhouse
rail and hs2 were never just about speed
they're about unlocking the economic
potential of the great cities of the
north and this plan leaves some of them
out all together
[Music]
bradford would have had a new station on
a new east-west line
now it remains the largest british city
not on a main line at all
this air conditioning manufacturer says
poor connections are holding back growth
over the next three years we're looking
for another 50 60 additional people
skilled people
and we can't always get that talent
pulled from within the bradford area we
have to go further afield and by not
having those real connections here now
makes it very very difficult to try and
attract
skilled people into this area because
the commuting distance just becomes
inaccessible for them
this is not the rail plan the north and
midlands was promised and it will be
more than a decade before its benefits
are felt a good job then that commuters
are used to waiting paul kelso sky news
in leeds